okay here we go thanks for the patience
on that one five standard let's roll
let's do it here all right all right
all right what is the rook
yeah that's raw at me there's typing in
the chaff that they're throwing the
birds they might be running with the
birds here the bird is the word
oh let's get on this diagonal before you
do how about that the anti bird
it's the anti bird or is it where's that
Bishop gonna go where is it gonna go oh
okay
Queen here is met with ninety five and
if I think I take the bishop I'm crazy
like Knight c7 TKO what about here let's
try that let's try that one Knight takes
pawn takes the knight gets kicked away
all the retreating what are they afraid
of what are they afraid of mmm let's try
that
and what next Bishop d7 to c6
or do I do this first this is the move I
want to be cautious of f5 hmm let's try
that in the 97 oh look at this look at
this all right that rook is um I guess
this pawn is gonna be pushed or as my
opponent getting out of any sneaky stuff
like are they gonna go b3 Bishop b2
let's see I don't know that they really
got anything out of the opening but it's
not always enough visit it's not always
enough to just claim equality and
there's got to be more okay no I'm not
fearful of a pawn move because I snipped
the knight and then grabbed this guy so
what's this guy doing what could he do
better he could probably come to c6 and
I guess I'm also vacating c8 right for
maybe pressure against this point let's
go they're still this move is no good
and I think this move is actually a good
one
cuz I think my opponents all bottled up
if they can't if they can't move that
pond I think they're not any better
we'll see though this is a weakened
point as a result of my last move so I
do have to keep in mind Knight g5 is
could be pinpointing it I have it
covered but um whatever alright let's
see let's see about taking this maybe
and then putting pressure on this
pottered I play here right away
let's play here right away decisions are
they gonna put a decision to my knight
and then here probably running
a bit too far away pawn push is actually
losing a punt I'm threatening to
actually I have it okay okay okay okay
I like my dark square Bishop too much
and I like the fact that this Knight is
kind of boxed out and I like that I have
this open file what I don't like is that
my opponent's putting pressure on this
pawn but I think I could defend it just
in time just before there's another guy
added to this point this night will be
kicked away soon enough in fact I'm once
again getting ready to win upon h6 chop
chop window material and probably close
to the game at that point because it's a
very significant pun and now the Nydia
is gonna be I guess ready to go has to
be content with playing to the edge
let's do that let's I don't think that
it can't be too happy about playing
there I can't be too happy so what do
you do what do you do what do you do
how about chop chop and push no I don't
want my bishop to get the door slammed
on it so no door slamming here although
I want to get this square somehow with
my knight can I make that happen
please mm-hmm
let's try this there may be a bishop
here I think bishop here is not good oh
here we go
oh this is an extremely committal move
with my opponent really do something
like that whoa they would they
definitely would do something like that
know one thing yep well tell you what
I'm gonna do what am I gonna do
chop chop here take take take and my
King is a bit more safe let's try that
let's just give it a whirl oh oh no no
no that's okay that's okay that's okay
that's okay
my bishop also comes to life and there's
possibilities for taking that queen out
night right and if the knight gets to f4
that could be a killer you know that
could definitely be a killer that Knight
to f4
all right let's chop this hopefully
everything's okay I was fearful of this
Queen move I was thinking it was checked
for some crazy reason
so hopefully I could exploit the fact
that I have a safer King so getting my
Bishop to d4 in other words is probably
fantastic and I think that I'm in a good
spot let's try this I did consider for
just a second rook here with the thought
of Bishop here since there's now three
pieces all of greater importance than my
bishop on this diagonal so that's a
maybe an interesting way to view things
I could trade Queens I could also take
here what's stopping me from doing
something like that let's try that let's
try it and then let's trade Queens
because if you got material that's
usually a good thing to do but I have
less than a minute to win it
I want what Bishop here please Queen
Treg Queen trade
I was a fearful of this rookie one I
want to trade cleans but I'm not so easy
just can't be easy can it oh okay well
let's try it I'm on this as well oh oh
that's a strong move that is a strong
move I missed that
let's try this can I somehow get this to
work oh is it gonna work please let me
say it's gonna work I'll take that night
I want that night he's going down it's
going down I got it block a ruski and
then this is a one king upon end game
are they gonna tip the king or they
gonna make me work for it they're gonna
make me work for it they're gonna make
me work for it they're saying show me
right now they're saying show me the
technique no I want my majority to roll
here less than 22 to 1 I have just
enough gas here just enough just enough
gas if the King goes here then I push
push less than 14 testing out my mouse
here he's testing out the mouse get out
of the way
run pun run fun oh just enough gas okay
ah good game good game good game
ah what a way to start a stream right
there giving me a wild run for my money
here okay
the bird was the word in this game and
well really it's like what Grand Prix
type of stuff okay
my transposition I don't know that um
this is the move is it is it really the
move is that the correct response after
Bishop b5 Knight here or should white
play Bishop c4 something tells me it's
Bishop c4 but I can't give a definitive
answer besides you know it just seemed
way too positive kind of coming all the
way back to e2 so probably Bishop c4 and
maybe White has to be content with maybe
an expansion with tempo a6 B 5 or e6 d5
in the center I felt that I was alright
once it got to this point so that anyhow
that's my like quick suggestion for
white but I felt that I was kind of
better and this is a key move I think I
don't know if right here but I've seen
it in other lines where you know you
take into account what it is that white
would like to do and sometimes it'll be
a maneuvering or excuse me a pivoting
about with the Queen by way of e1 h 4
and then f5 which does a lot of things
it's uh it's opening up the F file it's
opening up the diagonal for the bishop
and it's breaking down my king side
structure in some way but if I cement a
pawn on f5 I stopped all that right I'm
not allowing the F file to open up so
easily I'm not allowing the diagonal to
open up so just be aware of this
possibility to kind of restrain the
white attack this f5 move if you are
having to cope with the following
structure where there's a pawn on d3 d4
and f4 structure so be aware of how you
can maybe combat that and then we kind
of got into crazy mode again I think I
think I am a little bit better
here you know just kind of leaning on
generalizations basically I have the
bish up you know you look at the night
on the edge I have probably the safer
King
the more active rook right now and I
guess I guess it's just a little bit
more difficult for my opponent to be
playing I was trying to make this happen
it did turn out to like be beneficial in
the game but it was not without its care
that's for sure
Queen b3 it was something I completely
missed so I guess it kind of just
happened to turn out all right because I
have the Bishop d4 move but it was
certainly something I did not calculate
so and then a1 King and pawn and gain
from there okay
good game ace